your first Emmy I know right where where
are you keeping it right now is in a
closet waiting to be traveled home yes
tucked away in this little box I keep
showing it to people do you have
somewhere safe where you know you're
gonna put it
you're gonna display it like right when
you walk in your house put it on the
mailbox or something you know I'm saying
let people know like right yeah industry
for so long I literally grew up watching
you on television is it still fun to
come to these kinds of parties these
kinds of events yeah I mean yeah sure
why not everything is free language to
complain about you know exam you gotta
get your picture taken over boom boom do
celebrities come up to you and ask for
pictures with you some I'm the other
it's usually really asking yeah I'm a
huge fan of like everybody I see on my
CV so whenever I see somebody I'm always
like pretty please
or I have to tell them that I love them
one of the two I can't just like let the
moment go by just because I feel like
people appreciate like hearing that
their work is not being taken for
granted so I've tried to tell them like
you're great you're wonderful
I saw Edie Falco like a week ago and I
was riding my Citi bike and I was just
like miss Falco I love you and I kept it
moving you know I mean but like you
could tell she appreciated that song she
recognized I doubt it I have my hat on
you know he's just a black guy on a bike
when was the last time that you talked
to Kel Mitchell and what are the chances
that we would ever get like a good
burger reboot they've been talking about
it for forever so I mean I'm game I mean
whenever they figure out the script or
whatever but I've talked to him all the
time I just like was texting like two
days ago or something you guys are still
good friends absolutely like forever
like our families are close you know I
mean and like we've been through so much
together so like that kind of stuff just
doesn't go away like with time it just
gets better
yeah I did see that the SNL Twitter
account I think it was tweeted out who
should we have as musical guest this
season what are the chances we're
getting Ariana Grande
I feel like the chances are high like
right I feel like she'll be there almost
every week just because like long as
everything's going smooth with those two
and God bless them by the way how is it
to see Pete so in love it's awesome man
I mean we all need love and like to see
Pete you know be happy he goes through
so much you know I mean it's hard being
like a millennial on social media and
all of that so he's like just exposed to
a lot of like criticism or like you know
indirect negativity or whatever but like
he handles it really well you know he
believes in his like voice and his
stand-up and it's like I don't give her
attitude or whatever like being from
Staten Island and all of that he's proud
of that so I feel like he's got a solid
head on his shoulders but to see him
with you know a better half of himself
and like making him happy like that is
really nice you know because you're
right when you were growing up on
television you didn't have the Instagram
and the Facebook and the Twitter to deal
with that kind of is so constant you
know I mean it's like a constant
bombardment of like what other people
think of you you know what I mean and
that's it's it takes a lot to like
navigate through that are you glad that
you didn't have to deal with that for
sure I'm sensitive like it might have
been a whole nother experience yeah did
you get your wedding invite yet I mean
I'm not yet is it happening or they send
in the mail because like I might need to
make a call or two and be like yo what's
up like you trying to leave me out cuz
I'm going you're definitely invited I
can tell I'm going
[Music]